all right so you want to be the
strongest man in the world at the cost
of your hair while that is no problem
just follow this handy dandy training
guide and you will be there in no time
first up 100 pushups followed by 100
sit-ups and subscribing to the new world
view for regular anime or manga content
upload straight into your YouTube feeds
after which you will perform 100 squats
and then a short 10 kilometer run each
and every day good luck with your new
training regime hello and welcome to the
new world review your source for
everything anime and manga and today we
have some sort of news which is
something I don't usually cover it's a
pretty fascinating topic that I have
many a thought on which is that a
live-action one-punch man is apparently
in the works as reported by a variety
and as such it now joins the sea of
live-action anime adaptations in
development and production two other
notable ones being one piece and Cowboy
Bebop although to be fair both of those
are planned to be Netflix series while
one punch man is being turned into a
film and that is both good and bad news
and again to why in a bit but first
let's go through some of the details we
know from this here article so it opens
by saying Scott Rosenberg and Jeff
Pinker are set to write a live-action
film adaptation of the worldwide hit
monk sir is one punch man for Sony
Pictures so that's already mm perhaps
not such a great sign for one punch man
and I'm talking less about the riders
and more just Sony Pictures in general
because they're a very hit-or-miss
company and to be fair they do produce
some very enjoyable stuff most of which
I think comes from about two decades ago
like the original men in black for
example however at the same time that
might just be my nostalgia yes Sony is a
very mixed bag lately and they are
capable of making great films or at the
very least they are capable of funding
and/or distributing great films but with
one punch man we are obviously heading
solidly back into the superhero genre
where Sony into the spider-verse aside
as a pretty lackluster record now as for
the writers they both worked on venom
and I did not see venom because to be
completely honest I forgot it existed
although looking at the road and tomato
ratings that some pretty fascinating
stuff looks like it was almost
universally critically panned but
audiences responded to it way more
positively so that's something I guess I
will always trust the audience go over
the critics score but it says to me that
this here is no Oscar winner but it was
an enjoyable film and that's fine I
think that describes Sony pretty
perfectly actually enjoyable but nothing
groundbreaking and the two writers back
this up completely would Scott Rosenberg
are the credits including both recent
live action Jumanji films as well as
being an uncredited writer for ye old
spider-man
meanwhile Jeff Pinker also did the Jomon
Gees but what stands out to me is that
he wrote the amazing spider-man 2 which
is well it's not a good sign of that
movie was pretty damn awful in my
opinion so look in an ideal world I'm
not so sure that I would have given a
property like one punch man to this
particular set of creatives being Sony
and the two writers it was given their
past work it almost certainly suggests
that a live action one punch man will be
enjoyable but a kind of unfortunate
generic film and with a very real risk
of bombing entirely here are some
positive thoughts regarding that though
so when it comes to the spy demands and
everything these writers were generally
charged with crafting an original story
yes they were based on certain strains
of comics but it was not the straight-up
adaptation meanwhile I'm assuming
perhaps foolishly
that one punch man would be able to
alleviate some of my concerns because it
would be a straight-up adaptation and I
think there's a very strong argument to
be made in favor of adapting everything
up to and including the borås fight
within a single film because it is a
natural climax point of the series and
the story really isn't all that
complicated to get to that stage
comfortably nor the characters too
numerous to handle in fact one punch man
actually starts out as an incredibly
simple story although with that said you
would still need to a bridge combine and
get rid of quite a bit to make the
filmic runtime like I could see
saitama's entire story that took that
whole episode in the anime playing out
over a five minute action scene right at
the beginning of the film like say we
begin with a brief heated battle with
the subterranean race and Saitama wakes
up defeat some innocent goo punch as per
usual and sets up the standard of what
we're getting ourselves into
and then dedicates like two minutes to
show how he became what he is and I
don't think that would be entirely
unsatisfying the better or worse
character like Saitama doesn't actually
need a whole lot of depth and you can
get away with a very simple explanation
of who he is in fact simplicity and
Saitama synergized together quite
perfectly the thing as though this film
still needs to stick to the original
story in my opinion I really hate the
argument that is sometimes made that
films due to their medium need to
heavily adapt and almost start from
scratch with properties like these
because they won't translate nicely
until buy of action or into the runtime
of a feature-length film and I hate it
because it's just generally not true and
what it does is that it gives
individuals a whole new level of
creative freedom with the source
material that they really should never
have had access to
turning certain projects into modeled
messes absolutely should never have seen
the light of day take for example the
unrivaled masterpiece that is Dragonball
Evolution
which basically took a lot of names from
and ball and then slap them onto
characters and settings that completely
removed any semblance of who they were
or what they were supposed to represent
meanwhile what could have been done is
that they just adapt the first story arc
or two of Dragonball except maybe
piccolo be the main villain instead of
pilaf I mean the groundwork was all
there ready to be used but it was
rejected it's kind of like walking down
the street and deciding whose pavement
isn't good enough for me I'm going to
excavate it and build my own pavement
and then when you've started building
you all of a sudden realize that you
don't know the first thing about cement
mixing and you produce a very
uncomfortable journey it's also putting
a lot of unnecessary burden on the
writer to come up with an original story
that rivals also passes the source
material which is a ridiculous task
especially when you already have a
perfectly good story to work with just a
fun fact here the man who wrote the
final draft of Dragonball Evolution
James Wong insisted that he not be
credited as the co screenwriter which is
always very confidence inspiring in
regards to a project you know this film
is so good that the writer did not want
his name associated with it
now of course Dragonball Evolution was a
20th Century Fox production not Sony but
my concerns remain regardless because I
don't think that they have shown
particularly great judgment as a company
nor do their writers have an inspiring
body of work to draw optimism from now
there is another detail being that avi
arad and Ari rod of Arad productions are
producing the film as well and in
particular avi is responsible for
producing a whole slew of Marvel's Sony
and even Fox films almost exclusively
within the superhero genre mostly Sony
and Fox though avi was a producer for
the original Iron Man The Incredible
Hulk as well as spider-man Home Coming
and far from home but that's more or
less it for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so take from that what you will
to me it continues to reinforce the idea
that one punch man will be a competent
film because I have no doubt that the
rad production team are absolute guns
when it comes to that sort of schmick
Hollywood technical feel but at the same
time without a great script to work with
as well as the solid director which has
not been announced as of yet all the
amazing production in the world is kind
of meaningless as the old saying goes
you cannot polish it to it or I guess
you can but it will still be a turd
that's not how the old saying goes at
all all right though so what else do we
have here hugely popular both in Japan
and around the world one punch man
follows the story of Saitama a superhero
who can defeat any opponent with a
single punch it seeks to find a worthy
opponent after growing bored by a lack
of challenges in his fight against evil
created in 2009 by Japanese artist one
is a webcomic
punch man quickly went viral in 2012 it
was then published on Shu Asia's young
jump next with illustrations by Yusuke
Murata along with one the series sold
worldwide sales of over 30 million
copies when the English edition
published by viz media debuted in the
u.s. in 2015 first and second volumes
made the New York Times bestsellers list
and it was even nominated for an Eisner
& Harvey Award
since then the popularity of one punch
man has led to a critically acclaimed
unmei TV series as well as a video and
mobile game alright so nothing too
interesting that just some fun fluff
about the history of one punch man but
you know it's kind of interesting about
this they don't mention anything about
one being involved in this process in
any way just that he created the
original manga and I point this out
because in another live-action
adaptation that I'm following fairly
closely which I do primarily because I
have a whole channel dedicated to
discussing one piece however when that
was announced it was done so by stating
that the author of one piece said sure
Oda would be overseeing production of
the series and in fact the official
announcement was made by Oda himself
which for all of my concerns about a
live-action one piece is actually kind
of comforting and it's because whenever
Oda has a primary role in other
one-piece media like the recent films
they've all actually turned out pretty
damn well and there is no doubt in my
mind that it's because he is present and
adding that authentic touch to the
process as well as you know keeping
people in line and making sure that they
don't go insane with his characters and
his story but that is a very rare
situation for adaptations generally a
studio will buy the rights to a series
and then that's that deal done the
original creator will never have any
creative input into a live-action
adaptation and that's where I feel a
whole ton of them fail especially in the
anime realm so if there was one thing I
would be looking for in the future it
would be some kind of confirmation
regarding one's involvement at least to
some kind of consultant because there is
no one who knows these characters in
this world better that does of course
assume quite a bit I mean there's every
chance that one would not want to be
involved but for me that's just another
red flags in an ever-increasing sea of
other red flags for one punch man inside
to say Sony is very high on the property
given its popularity and the possibility
of adding another franchise to the
pipeline now you have probably the most
Hollywood statement I've ever heard
because it opens the window on this
entire scenario and it shouldn't be too
surprising because filmmaking is a
business like any other but yes this is
effectively just a cash grab the
excitement is all around snagging a
property that is already popular and
extracting some money by selling it
yourself and turning it into a potential
franchise because Sony is all about
trying enough
and failing to start up new franchises
good news though I guess because if Sony
understands and values one punch man and
it should command a significant amount
of attention and resources and thus once
again turn into what I would say is
nothing less than a competent film I
just personally don't think it has the
potential to be anything more than that
at this stage no but these details and
that's enough pessimism because here's
the deal here one punch man has its
moments of superb drama but it is not by
and large you know super serious story
in fact it may well be a perfect enemy
series for a company like Sony to poach
because a huge part of the one punch man
charm is it's almost parody like take on
the world of superheroes and
supervillains which does at least give
these creatives license to be a bit
weird because the series itself doesn't
take its events overly seriously not for
the most part anyway and even though
once again this was no Sony film but I'm
still thinking kind of Deadpool vibes a
great comedy piece but flares of
well-implemented action and a
surprisingly deep emotional core
underneath it all there's no denying it
can be done and one punch man is a prime
candidate to receive that sort of
treatment and with the few details we
know I actually feel much more positive
about a live-action one punch man than
most other projects we know of like the
live-action Akira film I won't even
happen today is that still a thing well
I'll start remember hearing about it was
that it was supposed to be directed by
Taika Waititi I go on stage anyway which
would have been kind of cool then again
Akira is just the polar opposite of one
punch man it requires such a commitment
to bring to life and you can't take it
as casually as you may be able to handle
one punch man in any case I'm going on a
bit of a tangent again but that is what
we know so far right now I don't think
it's anything to be too excited about
but it's not necessarily cause for
despair either but what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you keen for some
more anime lock content then please do
go and check out some of my other videos
or even subscribe to the channel for
regular anime manga business to live it
straight into your YouTube be but for
now this has been the New World review
and I'll see you next time